in the last video we covered the
essentials of regular expressions i'd
recommend watching that video first
if you haven't used regex before but in
this video i'm going to cover some
examples of how i use regular
expressions to clean data
and to scrape data from online so let's
get started for the first example we're
going to clean up this data i found
online
of airplane stowaways i first want to
start by grabbing the data so i'm going
to start highlighting it from the top of
the page
coming all the way down to the bottom
and shift clicking to highlight it all
i'm going to copy that go to my
spreadsheet and paste the data
in let me just expand these columns a
bit and make it so we can see
all the text and now i can start
creating new columns based on these
other columns to make our data more
interpretable
and easier to make visualizations from
so i'm going to make a new column name
called survive and it's going to signify
whether or not the stowaway actually
survived the flight
one thing i will mention though is that
in some of these cases there were
actually more than one stowaway
for example here there was two people
one of them survived and one didn't and
if i wanted to be thorough i could
either duplicate these rows
or create new columns for number of
survivors and number of deaths but for
the sake of this tutorial i'm just going
to ignore that and assume that there is
only one stowaway per each of these
cases
so to determine whether or not the
person in each case survived we can
actually look at the stairways fate
column
so all we really need to check is if the
word survived is in this column
we're going to do a regex match where
the first argument is this column
or the text that we want to match and
the second argument is going to be
the regex pattern that we're matching
for so i want to make sure that we're
grabbing both survived with the
uppercase s
and then survive with the lowercase s so
i'm going to use the brackets and put
either of those
in and then survived and then i can go
ahead and autofill
and we can scroll through and just do
some spot checks and it looks pretty
good to me the next data point we want
to grab
are the ages of the stowaways in each of
these cases so for our survive column we
were using regex match which would just
return true or false depending on
whether or not that pattern was in the
text but here we actually want to use
the regex extract function which will
extract a substring of the text
based on a regular expression again
we're going to use that
column for our data and now for a
pattern since we know it's going to be a
number
that could be theoretically of any
length we're going to do slash d
plus which will match one or more
instance and again we can autofill and
we get our ages and we do have some nas
where their their age is unknown but
that's totally fine now we have the date
but let's say we want to get the
specific year that this happened
so again we're going to use that regex
extract function select that
cell and now we're going to do slash d
and we know it's always going to be four
numbers
we can hit enter and we get this error
that the number can't be coerced to text
all we need to do is come over here and
because this
column is formatted as a date we just
need to change it to plain text and now
our year actually shows up
and we can expand the column to get each
of the years so i'll make a new column
called departure
and we're going to start out with that
regex extract function again we'll
specify that cell
and we don't know if it's going to be
one word or multiple words for the
departure
so we'll do dot star which will grab
everything and then we can specify
that there's going to be a hyphen and we
can close that off
now the issue here is that there are
actually different types of hyphens
being used in this text
it's difficult to notice but the hyphen
here after santa maria is actually a
different character than the one up here
so just so our pattern knows to search
for either both of them we're going to
use those square brackets
and paste in that hyphen that we grabbed
and now we'll get coupon here but i
don't want that hyphen to appear so i'm
going to put our capture of the dot star
within the parentheses
which means that we're only capturing
that group and that'll be reflected here
i can go ahead and expand that column
and we're going to do something similar
for
arrival we can actually copy this text
because it's going to be pretty similar
and paste it except now we want to grab
what's after the hyphen
so that looks pretty good to me we got
these five new columns based on
our old data and if we want to build any
visualizations off of this
because the data is a lot cleaner now
it'll be much easier to do and obviously
we didn't need to do this in google
sheets we could have done this in our
python
but i did want to illustrate how easy
google sheets is to use for regular
expressions
and it's just easier to see our data
especially when we're working with a
smaller data set
in this next example i'm interested in
the new sources being used
on the politics subreddit for each of
these posts after the title of the post
we see the source of the article
i could use python or r and write some
code to build a web scraper but it'd be
a lot easier if i could just copy the
text
use some regular expression and extract
these urls so that's exactly what i'll
do
so i'm literally just scrolling and
scrolling to get as much data to
populate on the page as i can but once
i'm satisfied or i've run out of pages
i'm going to start selecting the text at
the bottom
i'll scroll all the way up back up to
the top and shift click
so we grab all that text and i'll copy
it and i'll head over
to regex 101 which is the website we
used in the last video and i'll paste in
my text
so if we're just trying to grab the urls
which are in these parentheses
it's actually not too difficult to do
this we want to search for a left
parenthesis
and we have to use that escape character
here we want to be careful here though
because we want to make sure
expression is grabbing all the urls so
the websites where it's
thedomainname.com.org but also the ones
where there might be multiple dots like
independent.co.uk so we're going to be
searching for
either word characters or periods up
until a right parenthesis
so we're going to use the square
brackets and we're going to search for
word characters
or periods and we have to use an escape
character here we can close that off and
it's going to be one or more
so we'll use a plus and it's going to
end with the right parenthesis
so now we're fully matching the
parentheses and the url
and everything looks like it should be
highlighted the way it is but again we
want to put this in a capture group so
we're not selecting the parentheses so
i'm going to add
a left parenthesis right around those
brackets
and a right parenthesis right after the
plus and now it'll highlight
our grouping green so we're not grabbing
the left and right parentheses
and now to actually extract these out of
the text we can go over to the right
where it says export matches
come down to plain text and uncheck
include full match
we can copy this to our clipboard open
up our google sheet and there we go we
get all of our urls from those posts
so this is the very lazy one minute
version of web scraping
where we're getting one specific text
but what if we want to generate a whole
table from some data online
in this example i've got the top rated
breweries throughout the world according
to untapped there's no csv i can
download here
even though the data is all on this page
and again i could use our python to
write a web scraper and if you want to
know how to do that i actually do have
some videos on web scraping with r which
you can check out right there
but we can actually use regular
expressions to pretty quickly get this
into a nicely formatted table so again
i'll start out by highlighting some of
the data going down to the bottom
shift clicking to select it all and
copying it and i'll go over to regex 101
and paste in our data and the first
thing we're going to do is come to the
substitution tab
and you see we have a lot of extraneous
new lines and it's going to make things
a little tricky so what we want to do
first
is replace the newline plus with just a
single new line character and that will
get rid of all those extra spaces then i
could just copy this data
paste it up here and go back to match
i'm going to scroll up to the top and
get rid of that first new line
and now we can actually start grouping
off and selecting our data so just to
break down what we're looking at this
would be one row of data
we've got the brewery name here the
location the type of brewery
how many beers they have how many people
have rated them and then their average
rating
so we can start specifying our regular
expression to capture our data
and anything we actually want to have in
our final table we need to make sure we
put parentheses around
so we'll grab the brewery name and this
is pretty easy we're just gonna do
a dot star and just to make this a
little easier i'm actually gonna disable
global which will only do one match just
so we know exactly what we're selecting
to begin with and then we can apply it
to the whole string
so we've got our brewery name now
there's gonna be a new line
and then there's gonna be the location
so again we can do dot star
to grab everything then there's a new
line then there's the type of brewery
so dot star then there's a new line and
now we want to grab the number of beers
that they serve
we could do slash d plus here but there
might be a comma let's say if it was a
thousand it would be one comma zero zero
zero and we'd wanna make sure that we're
grabbing that comma as well so we'll
make a parentheses to open up our
capture group
and now it could either be a digit or it
could be a comma
we'll close our bracket and then this
will occur one or more time and we'll
close our capture group
and now we're getting this 140 but even
if there was a comma here we would still
get that too we don't need to capture
this word beers
so i'm actually going to explicitly
specify a space
and then the word beers we do want to
capture the number of ratings
and we can do that similarly to how we
did the number of beers
so open parentheses bracket it's either
going to be a number or a comma and it's
going to happen one or more times
then we'll close it off now we get this
number right here then we see there's a
space
and the word ratings then we have a new
line we have a left parenthesis
so we're going to do an escape character
left parenthesis and then
a normal parenthesis to start our
capture group and kind of similar to how
we had before where we had either a
number
comma here we're going to have a number
or a period and then
some more numbers so we could do d and
then
slash period to escape that character
and that'll occur one or more times
we'll close off our capture group and
then we'll specify our right parenthesis
and if we look over here on the right we
see our full match and then what each of
the groups correspond to
so just to reiterate group one we've got
our brewery name then the location
the type of brewery the number of beers
the number of ratings
and then the average rating and if i go
back to these regex options and i change
this to global it'll keep selecting
after the first match
and our data looks pretty good now we
just want to get this into a table
format or csv
so we'll go over to substitution and for
the substitution since we have
our six capture groups we just need to
output our groups and we can do that
with the dollar signs
so dollar sign one dollar sign two but
one really quick thing is that with the
location
and with some of these numbers there are
commas and these commas right here are
to specify that we want to separate
these out into columns but
if there are commas in our actual text
google sheets will get kind of confused
with interpreting it
so we need to put quotes around our
groups
that way the commas within the text stay
within the text and aren't treated as
separate columns
so we've got our first capture group
second capture group
third capture group fourth fifth
and sixth and then all we need to do is
copy all of this text
go back to our google sheet paste it in
here and it pastes it all into one
column but we can really easily
go to data and go to split text into
columns and now we have a nice and clean
data set in just a couple of minutes
now this method works best when the data
is really consistent and there aren't
any fields that would appear
for some data points and not others but
if you learn regex well there are
definitely situations where it's easier
and quicker to use regex to clean and
scrape data than it is to open up r
or python and write 20 lines of code to
do the same thing
anyway i'm going to link some additional
regex resources in the description
i recommend checking them out like this
cheat sheet right here which is pretty
helpful but anyway thanks for watching
and i'd recommend checking out my other
videos if you're interested in these
kinds of data topics